Traductor: Marlén Scholand Cámara
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Antes de los imperios y la realeza,
antes de la cerámica y la escritura,
antes de herramientas metálicas y armas,
habia queso
Ya en 8000 aC,
los primeros agricultores neolíticos
que vivían en la Media Luna Fértil
comenzaron
un legado de fabricación de queso
casi tan antiguo
como la civilización misma.
El auge de la agricultura dio lugar
a ovejas y cabras domesticadas,
que los antiguos agricultores
criaban para obtener leche.
Pero cuando se deja a temperatura cálida
durante varias horas,
esa leche fresca se empezaba a agriar.
Sus ácidos lácticos causaron que
las proteínas coagularan
formando grupos blandos.
Al descubrir esta extraña transformación,
los agricultores drenaron
el líquido restante,
más tarde denominado lactosuero,
y descubrieron que
los glóbulos amarillentos se podían comer
frescos como comida suave y untable.
Estos grupos o cuajadas se convirtieron
en los bloques de construcción de queso,
el cual finalmente sería envejecido,
prensado y madurado
en una diversa cornucopia
de delicias lácteas.
El descubrimiento del queso dio
a las personas neolíticas
una enorme ventaja de supervivencia.
La leche era rica en proteínas
esenciales, grasas y minerales.
Pero también contenía
altas cantidades de lactosa.
Un azúcar difícil de procesar
para muchos estómagos antiguos y modernos.
El queso, sin embargo, ofrecía ventajas
de la leche con mucha menos lactosa.
Y como se podía conservar y guardar,
estos nutrientes esenciales
podían ser consumidos
durante las hambrunas
y largos inviernos.
Se encontraron algunos fragmentos
de cerámica del 7º milenio aC en Turquía
con residuos reveladores
de queso y mantequilla.
A finales de la Edad de Bronce,
el queso era un producto estándar
en el comercio marítimo
a lo largo del Mediterráneo oriental.
En las ciudades-estado densamente
pobladas de Mesopotamia,
el queso se convirtió en un elemento
básico de la vida culinaria y religiosa.
Algunos de los primeros escritos conocidos
incluyen registros administrativos
de las cuotas de queso,
listando una variedad de quesos
para diferentes rituales y poblaciones
en toda Mesopotamia.
Los registros de civilizaciones
cercanas en Turquía
también hacen referencia al cuajo.
Este subproducto animal, producido
en los estómagos de ciertos mamíferos,
puede acelerar y controlar la coagulación.
Con el tiempo esta sofisticada
herramienta de fabricación
se extendió por todo el mundo,
dando paso a una gran variedad
de quesos nuevos y más duros.
Y aunque algunas culturas alimentarias
conservadoras
rechazaron la delicadeza láctea,
muchos la incorporaron
y rápidamente agregaron
sus propios sabores locales.
Los mongoles nómadas utilizaron
la leche de yak
para crear cuñas duras y secas de Byaslag.
En Egipto se disfrutaba
del queso cottage con leche de cabra,
filtrando el suero con esteras de caña.
En el sur de Asia, la leche se coagulaba
con una variedad de ácidos alimentarios,
como el jugo de limón, vinagre o yogur
y luego para secar en panes de paneer.
Este queso suave y untable se puede
agregar a los curries y salsas,
o simplemente frito como
un plato rápido de comida vegetariana.
Los griegos produjeron ladrillos
de queso feta salado en salmuera,
junto a una variedad más dura similar
al pecorino romano de hoy.
Este queso rallado se producía en Sicilia
y se utilizaba en platos
de todo el Mediterráneo.
Bajo el dominio romano,
el "queso seco" o "caseus aridus"
se convirtió en una comida esencial
para los 500 000 soldados que custodiaban
las vastas fronteras del Imperio Romano.
Y cuando el Imperio Romano
occidental se derrumbó,
la quesería continuó evolucionando.
En las mansiones que salpicaban
el campo medieval europeo.
En los cientos de monasterios
benedictinos repartidos por toda Europa.
Los monjes medievales experimentaron
sin pausa con diferentes tipos de leche,
prácticas de fabricación de queso,
y procesos de maduración que han hecho
a muchos quesos de hoy populares
Parmesano, Roquefort, Munster
y varios tipos suizos
fueron refinados y perfeccionados
por estos clérigos de la quesería.
En los Alpes, la quesería suiza
fue particularmente exitosa
produciendo gran cantidad
de quesos de leche de vaca.
A finales del siglo XIV
el queso alpino de la región gruyere
de Suiza se había vuelto tan rentable
que un estado vecino invadió
las tierras altas Gruyere
para controlar
el creciente comercio del queso.
El queso siguió siendo
popular durante el Renacimiento,
y la Revolución Industrial sacó
la producción del monasterio.
y la metió en las maquinas.
Hoy en día, el mundo produce cerca de
22 mil millones de kg de queso al año
que se trasporta y consume
en todo el mundo.
Pero 10 000 años después de su invención,
las granjas locales siguen
los pasos de sus ancestros neolíticos,
elaborando a mano uno de los alimentos
más antiguos y favoritos de la humanidad.